one Morgan Stanley analyst is out this
morning saying that the electric car
company Tesla might be building its own
uber called Tesla mobility Tesla chief
executive Elon Musk refuses to comment
but the news is sending the shares of
the company higher with more now my
co-host for the next hour Betty tell us
about this right I don't know if you
remember but a few weeks ago when Tesla
had their conference call actually I
talked with you about this I'm Adam you
asked right and then he was asked you
didn't say very much right at the time
though the speculation was more about
whether Tesla and uber might partner up
and what a clever idea that would be
right so Tesla would sell all their
electric cars or some of them to Ober
and we do a fleet sale of some time
that's a very straight and very
interesting idea but kind of hidden in
that question a little bit that didn't
get picked up as much from Adam Jonas to
to Elon Musk is what about Tesla
building their own entire uber company
and how much more interesting that could
be for Elon Musk so he just went ahead
you know they may as well just hire this
guy because he's thinking about these
ideas for them right or maybe he looked
and raised and raised the price target I
believe so he did this while he was
writing a research report raise the
price target I was 65 is the new one for
65 it's trading right now at around 250
and he so Adam dubs it himself
Tesla Mobility now remember the company
has not said anything about this so he's
just sort of you know speculating here
but what he's saying is that if they in
fact created their own on-demand car
service where they used the Tesla Model
3 cars they had their own fleet this
would create the demand that that Elon
Musk has talked about the charging
network arounds around the country ating
a customer he's creating a whole market
right yes creating customer and creating
a whole market so the energy business
would also see see vigorous demand
obviously from from a service like this
and what Adam Jonas predicts is Tesla
could triple their revenue by 2029 so
the revenue right now is at about five
billion dollars you know if they stay on
track so they could triple this by you
know in
in a few years wait a few years but
doesn't Tesla have difficulty now just
meeting the demand for the automobiles
that they already have and they can't
get the new models out on time and in
big production numbers that and also
that they're having trouble just putting
out their new models right so they're
Model X the SUV has undergone several
delays but it looks like it's on track
for the fall you know there's other
analysts who say just everybody take a
big deep breath okay you know let's
let's just step back and realize that
the Tesla stock and the company itself
is really not going to accelerate or
prove itself until they get this model 3
out which isn't expected for another
year or so or a couple of years and the
model 3 is supposed to be the more
mass-market $5,000 car that everybody is
going to every that everyone is going to
drive and that is that is also going to
be by the way part of the demand for
that Giga factory in Las Vegas right
there yes to build the battery a huge
right the lithium-ion batteries so you
know all of this is you know you're
putting your your bet on the future
that's what you're really doing when
you're buying Tesla's